قضى بليك بارغوتزي أكثر من ثلاثة
أشهر في وحدة
العناية المركزة بالمستشفى بعد تعاقده مع كوفيد 19 ، احتاج
إلى عملية زرع رئتين للبقاء على قيد الحياة
، وهو يبلغ من العمر 24 عامًا فقط ، وانضمت
إليه والدته شيريل
نوكيلو بليك وشيريل ، ويسعدنا جدًا أن
تكون بليك يسعدنا ذلك  انظر إلى
مدى حالتك الجيدة ، أعني أنك كما
قلنا للتو
تبلغ من العمر 24 عامًا فقط وأنت على وشك الموت من
مرض كوفيد ،
كيف حالك اليوم ،
فأنا أفضل حالًا الآن وفي الحقيقة
أنا في الواقع على
وشك الخروج من المستشفى
المستشفى للذهاب إلى
مركز إعادة التأهيل البدني للمرضى الداخليين ،
فأنا يزداد قوة يومًا بعد يوم ،
ولا يمكنني المشي بعد ولكن هذا هو
الهدف
وأم تعلم أنني سأقضي بعض
الوقت في هذا المركز لمجرد أن أصبح قويًا
و  عدت بمفردي لإطعام الطعام مرة أخرى جيدًا ، نعلم جيدًا
أنه سيكون طريقًا طويلاً حقًا
،
ولمجرد إخبار الناس عن
المحنة التي مررت بها بالفعل
لمجرد تلخيص القليل من
التاريخ
في 27 مارس لقد ذهبت  إلى
حفلة موسيقية داخلية
ثا  كان هناك أسابيع قبل أن تكون
مؤهلاً للحصول على اللقاح ، لذلك
لم يتم تطعيمك بعد
وأنا أعلم أنك تعتقد أنك
ألقيت القبض على كوفيد
في تلك الحفلة الموسيقية وأنك ندمت على ذهابك إلى
تلك الحفلة الموسيقية بعد يومين من
شعورك بالمرض في غضون أيام قليلة من ذلك.
كنت
في المستشفى مصابًا بالتهاب رئوي خفي ثنائي
مما يعني في كلتا الرئتين
وأم أعلم أنك كنت صادقًا في
أنك كنت تستخدم الـ vaper قبل ذلك ولكن مرة أخرى
تبلغ من العمر 24 عامًا
وهذا هو السبب الذي يجعل الأطباء يعتقدون أنك مرضت للغاية
الآن نحن في الواقع  كان هذا هو السؤال الذي
اتصلت به مع طبيبه بالأمس
وقال الدكتور ريد
إنه لم يكن vaping حقًا الذي يعتقد أنه
حصل للتو على حمولة فيروسية كاملة
ربما سعلها شخص ما
مباشرة في الفضاء ،
وارتفعت جزيئات أنفه
وعينيه و  فمه ،
لذلك أعني أن الـ vaping لا يساعد ولكن
بالنسبة
لأم بالطريقة التي استجاب بها بليك ، فقد حصل للتو
على
اتصال مباشر كامل به ، نعم ، من
الواضح أن
والدته كانت مرعبة بالنسبة لك ، لقد
أصبح الأمر أسوأ فقط أعني  af  إذا تم
إدخاله إلى المستشفى ، فقد ساء الأمر في
غضون أسبوعين ، حيث كان يستخدم جهاز التنفس الصناعي
بعد أسبوعين من توقف قلبه ،
وأعتقد أنه ثلاث مرات منفصلة
في يوم الأم ،
ويمكنني أن أتخيل كيف
شعرت بالعجز هل كنت تعتقد أنه ذاهب
لجعل الأمر في
الواقع لا ، فأنا أخدر نوعًا
ما ، فأنا لم أتخلى عن الأمل مطلقًا
،
كانت المشكلة في البداية هي العثور
على سرير ecmo له ثم جعلناه يطير إلى أتلانتا
أو في الواقع طار الدكتور باريت و
أحضره وأعاده ووضعه على جهاز
ecmo مثل جهاز التنفس الصناعي فائق الشحن ،
إنه مثل آلة الرئة الاصطناعية ،
لذلك لا يزال على جهاز
التنفس الصناعي نوعًا ما يترك
رئتيه يرتاحان ولكن الدم سيُسحب
من جسده  من خلال جهاز
أكسجين
يمنحك معرفة جيدة
بالدم المؤكسج إلى
أعضائه وكان في تلك الأسابيع
التسعة وتسعة أسابيع ، ثم
تلقيت في وقت ما خبرًا
بأنه سيحتاج إلى عملية زرع رئة مزدوجة.
لقد أدركت أثناء ذلك أنك كنت على دراية بأنك
ستحتاج إلى عملية زرع رئة ،
لأنني كنت نائمًا لمعظم فترة
مكوثي في المستشفى ، لكنني أتذكر عن
ما قالوا إن
ي بحاجة إلى زوج من الرئتين الجديدتين وت
حدث أمي معي عن
الإيجابيات والسلبيات ، ومن الواضح أنني إذا اخترت
عميلاً وكنت سأموت ، لذا
انتهزت الفرصة التي
قمت بها للعملية وسارت الأمور على ما
يرام وأنت تعلم أنني سعيد لكوني على قيد الحياة
ومن الواضح أن لدي فرصة ثانية